padam s'allume juju non casimir sois
gentil mais je suis en qui j'ai même
obtenu l'an dernier le premier prix le
prix du plus gentilles et casimir us
alors fais moi plaisir ne m'appelle plus
juju j'ai un prénom qui est très jolie
que j'aime beaucoup je ne veux pas qu'on
le change pas très bien juju au pardon
très bien julie excuse moi je ferai des
efforts tu sais quand je suis de très
bonne humeur à bien j'ai envie de
t'appeler juju un puck assez gentil
d'essayer mais dis moi qu'est ce qui te
rend de bonne humeur aujourd'hui
et bien c'est demain l'anniversaire de
ma tante ernestine et elle prépare pour
tous les casimir us qui vais me fouetter
un bon anniversaire
un délicieux gâteau au cloud by bull
gars si formidable tu vas pouvoir te
régaler oui si je ne suis pas un
discrète qu'est ce que c'est que cette
lettre ça c'est une lettre pour la
prévenir de mon arrivée
oui parce qu elle ne prépare que le
nombre de garde fous nécessaires aux aux
invités ne va jamais partir à temps
allait pourquoi parce que le facteur est
déjà passée aujourd'hui et qu'elle ne
partira demain ça sera trop tard
mais c'était pouvant me tarde qu'est ce
que je vais faire alors écoute pour une
fois tu peux aller chez sa tante et en
estime sans lui avoir écrit je suis sûr
que si tu lui dis exactement ce qui
s'est passé elle te donnera quand même
un gros bout de gâteau
bon je suis sûr que ce n'est pas vrai
pourquoi parce que si ma tante vers les
styles et la meilleure pâtissière des
casimir us c'est aussi celle qui a le
plus mauvais caractère mais si je ne
vais pas écrit pour lui souhaiter un bon
anniversaire
elle pensera que je suis venu simplement
parce que j'ai senti l'odeur des bons
gâteaux vient de me mettre à dos à
nantes of casimir tu veux que je te
fasse un gros gloubiboulga pour te
consoler sus un rien ne remplace les
gâteaux de ma tante ernestine je te
comprends je ne me vexe pas mais il faut
que je te quitte
tu vas pas me laisser seul je suis
désolé mais je dois aller chercher une
caisse de bombo qui arrive au bateau et
j'ai juste le temps je ne sais même pas
si je ne suis pas du genre tard bon
allez on voit moizini
mademoiselle julie tournée à bicyclette
non non non non ce n'est pas ma tournée
non je viens vous apporter un télégramme
été l'écrin de voilà merci facteur cause
panne camion stock livraisons retardées
un jour stop ce n'est pas grave j'espère
un non pas du tout grâce à votre
bicyclette vous êtes arrivé à temps
j'allais partir pour le porte et faire
le voyage pour rien
mais j'en suis bien content mademoiselle
julie bon je continue ma tournée parce
que j'ai du travail vous savez
aujourd'hui un secteur 1 casimir qu'est
ce que c'est
voilà de quoi réside le problème on est
content j'ai déjà assez d'ennuis comme
ça si en plus tu me fait faire un
problème alors on écoute la grâce à un
télégramme tu vas pouvoir aller
tranquillement manger du gâteau je n'ai
pas tenté un estime qu'est ce que c'est
telle est grave c'est ce que je viens de
donner à julie cette lettre à laquelle
on ne comprend rien adams est écrit en
style télégraphique tu vas voir c'est
très simple quand on envoie un
télégramme il le faut écrire que les
mots importants par exemple je prends
celui là coup span camion veut dire à
cause de la panne du camion stop est un
mot à part qui remplace la ponctuation
c'est à dire les virgules les points les
points virgules par exemple et
livraisons retardées un jour veut dire
la livraison est retardée d'un jour
bon j'ai compris mais je ne comprends
pas pourquoi grand sahara télégramme je
pourrai manger du gâteau demain chez ma
tante ernestine mais parce qu'elle ne
recevra aujourd'hui qu'elle ne sera pas
surprise quand tu arrives à mais tu m'as
dit que le bateau était déjà parti mais
casimir le télégramme ne prennent pas le
bateau tu me donnes ton texte
je le porte à la poste là un de mes
collègues le tape sur une sorte de
machine à écrire et immédiatement de
l'autre côté de la mer alors grâce à un
câble sous-marin ton télégramme
s'inscrit automatiquement sur une autre
machine et il ne reste plus qu'à la
portée at internet
voilà bon mais alors il me faut écrire
que certains mots ah oui oui c'est ça tu
es vraiment obligé de n'écrire que
certains mots un parce que on compte le
nombre de mots et opel oui parce que
plus on n'écrit plus on paye un bon ben
alors j'ai conclu je ne remettrai quand
les mots très important voilà donc toi
mon crayon julie oui bien sûr tiens le
voilà temps à casimir bon voilà une
formule spéciale et des formules à
quelques heures je l'emportent 1
d'accord bon alors voilà voilà déjà prêt
à partir facto mais mademoiselle julie
les télégrammes c'est sa créateur
munichois n'a jamais le temps au revoir
au revoir facteurs une deux une deux une
deux une deux une deux une deux une deux
une deux une deux une de casimir
qu'est-ce que ça mais tu vas être épuisé
oh oui mais ça ne fait rien tu sais il
faut que j'aie vraiment très fin demain
pour pouvoir manger
l'énorme gâteau de maths interne et
steen et généraux moi quel ton aura
préparé une très grosse comme ça j'en
suis certain alors une deux une deux une
deux uniques 2 qu'est ce que c'est que
d'être un facteur g un télégramme pour
toi bon je crois que c'est la réponse de
ta tante anne st lô
elle est gentille à de m'avoir répondu
au foncier vite l'annnonce de ta visite
a dû lui faire très plaisir
alors pas de goinfres mon anniversaire
reste chez toi stoppe tout ernestine
mais jolie ne vaut pas conseillé de
manger du gâteau chez elle c'est
incroyable qu'on avait tu écris dans son
télégramme
mais je l'avais me viendrait manger
gâteau stock prépare grosse part se dire
oui à l'eau enfin tu ne m'a même pas dit
que tu venais l'avoir pour son
anniversaire
oui c'est de votre faute enfin comment
peux tu dire une chose pareille je ne
comprends pas moi moi je voulais mettre
bon anniversaire
mais vous m'avez dit que dans un
télégramme il ne fallait même que les
mots très important
[Musique]
à